tomorrow is national sunday day and to
celebrate why not have the ice cream
sundae of your dreams
rocky is live at sloane's inside the
venetian to show us where ice cream
fantasy becomes reality rocky
you look like a show girl yes as you
said
ice cream fantasies if you can see
this place is the land of ice cream
dreams and
toy dreams it's just it's so beautiful
in here i love it
america you are the manager here at
sloanes in the venetian and tomorrow's
national sunday day
how do you guys celebrate so we
celebrate with more than eight creations
we have high premium quality ice cream
uh-huh we have different flavors
so like yes like but this is going to be
our flower child
it has apple pie ice cream it has apple
pie ice cream
man and coffee and donuts wow okay they
said be careful with the feathers on my
mic
sorry guys it's hard being fabulous okay
it's loans
all right so this is made apple apple
pie ice cream
and what was the other one so you got
carrot cake carrot cake ice cream so is
that what you guys specialize in just
unique flavors yes they are so what we
do we have to make the things like we
have to make the pie
and then blend it in our ice cream and
then get ice cream ice cream sundaes all
over your fingers too
oh my gosh okay so of course sloane's is
all about fantasy land it's all
it's combining disneyland and willie
walker right you have your high premium
quality
ice cream you're gonna have your fresh
baked cookies brownie you're gonna have
your
caramel apples candy apples you're gonna
have your truffles
i love it you're not gonna miss anything
here you're not gonna miss anything
because we also have
things to buy toys to buy for your kids
for for yourself whatever you want
okay so we have another one that we want
to make this is the sand castle sundays
and
very very cool so let's make it so we're
going to have
is your tank as a bucket look at that
super cute it's gonna have a half a
cookie at the bottom okay
with five scoops you have your carrot
cake your peanut butter your scouts
honor this mint let me show you guys
you guys see that oh my gosh okay so
what makes this
what makes this it's so unique because
you're missing your high five your hot
caramel
right your wet one nuts you can add two
toppings whipped cream
especially decoration that's all you
need is
the sunglasses and you're ready and of
course what i love about here is that
the ice cream is not just for one
obviously
your entire family can share that yeah
okay so let's put the sunglasses on to
commemorate
national sunday day tomorrow you guys
come celebrate
at sloane's in the venetian and tomorrow
also i want you guys to know that
they're giving away ice cream to
veterans for free right yes we are
what better way to come down to slums
than that
happy national sunday day guys come back
in the four we'll show you more
you know it's good when they give you a
shovel to eat the ice cream without
wanting
we'll check back in with you during the
4pm newscast